well a hidden gem here in the valley
catches fire now the owners really need
some help to bring it back
mema's kitchen is over on charleston in
commerce they're known for colombian and
mexican dishes
it was destroyed last week sally
jeremiah shares their story mimas
was a food truck that we started about
two years ago with my family carlos
arturo monsalve castro along with his
uncle juan riven on
marieli diaz are from bucaramanga
colombia and realized las vegas needed a
fast food colombian concept
the sachi papa were like loaded hot
loaded fries as well too
fried plantains with toppings on top
from empanadas
to hot dogs and burgers they served it
all my uncle is miguel
my auntis maya so that's why mima's is
the name of mimas right there even
reinventing themselves this past year
offering a fusion of colombian and
mexican plates it was a way for
my family to share some of our
traditions and our food and our flavors
but then the worst imaginable happen
unfortunately there seemed to have been
an electrical issue
that started after hours and that turned
into
a fire we got a call from the tire shop
that
was right next to our our food truck and
so we went there and we tried to
extinguish the pie or the fire
extinguisher but
everything was pretty much burned down
shuttering their business they worked so
hard to build people reaching out and
asking
you know what happened and asking when
we're going to be open up again so we
can serve them and now many loyal
customers in las vegas
want this corner to come back to life
we're still trying to figure out how we
can
make mimas come back better and stronger
than before we all as a family
have for all the community is simply
thank you
sally jaramillo 8 news now mima's
kitchen is a total loss they're hoping
to raise ten thousand dollars to get
back in business so far they have raised
four thousand
now we shared their story and gofundme
it's over on eightnewsnow.com